l'amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour savoir qui est amoureux dix sachets
vraiment je vous le dis si vous nous
rejoignez même si vous ne connaissez pas
les chroniqueurs parce qu'il ya un film
qui va arriver dans un instant sachez
qu'il ya une personne ici autour de la
table qui est amoureux ou amoureuse
d'une personne de l'équipe vraiment mais
amoureuse folle aux amoureux sous alors
première à 10
pour trouver la personne c'est ça
il a toujours une étoile
alors
virginie comme vous êtes en quête dans
le morvan
oui bien sûr enquêter avec moi c'est ça
vous avez un premier indice dans les
yeux d'une fille il ya toujours une
étoile qui veut dire que c'est donc un
garçon hier moureu une star vernon ça
veut dire tout simplement que c'est une
fille vous aider j'ai l'impression que
le club va vite adam suivent alors
sachez je vais vous montrer des sms que
j'ai reçues et j'ai jolie la personne et
oula oula et on verra bien où là à sa
botte comme donc attaquer si ça peut te
tue le proprio de cette histoire d'amour
c'est à yagma trop de roger ackroyd
jeunes élus à ces abris ouais bah merci
on s'en fout les sms qu'on a reçu
voilà que j'ai reçu de cette personne
qu'elle stresse première sms regardez je
suis amoureux amoureux
je vous jure que c'est que du vrai
prénom c'est pas mon écriture les mecs
qu'on avait
[Applaudissements]
raymond regarder au mexique au numéro 2
si je peux me permettre ne fait plus les
faits parce que je suis un texto 3d j'en
sais que c'est pas daniel adresse je
suis ensemble c'est une italienne me
rappelle même pas s'il allait bien je
pense à lui elle
j'ai vraiment un truc regardez le texto
numéro 4 tu m'as fait froid dans le dos
et celui-là dès qu'il me touche où elle
me disait trop regarder ensuite si vous
me touche et n'était je la trouve
intelligent de sensible et drôle
elle parle de quelqu'un de l'équipe oui
doit regarder
regardez dernier intéresse que j'ai reçu
là je regarde leur ip c'est nul mais je
bave non ces sms vous adresser à vous le
dirais pas qu'elles bave
c'est une fille dans cette fille c'est
une jeune c'est une très jolie selma
l'autre à dire basta le 17 août très
vite les contours de cap
je vais vous dire de qui il s'agit
francesca rue saint patrick
[Applaudissements]
l'expression chiant sens christina
chaudière à came voit qu'à six noms
tabac c'est un peut pas être moi
francesca beau et être daniel quand même
faire un coup de jeune rien vous
francesca vous gérez pont est vraiment
amoureuse elle m'a dit de le dire tu
m'as dit autorisée oui vous aviez dit
que vous diriez vite fait jamais assez
mais vous alors alors je vous le dis
elle est amoureuse d'un garçon
ben non elle va elle va nous le dire
mais tu vas tu vas le dire parce que non
tu m'a dit je veux le dire vraiment
parce que et ça dérange loi c'est beau
c'est pour aller c'est beau c'est bon
c'est bon mais le gars en face il veut
bien qu'on le dise ah bah on sait pas
c'est pas les le gars nous dira d'où
vient alors manchester ce que tu veux le
dire où tu que je le dise les îles
non mais vous préférez fait ça va
prendre c'est ce qu'attendait attendez
j'ai envie de savoir si elle va bien
c'est comme un peu stressant mais pas du
tout ça s'est fait non je vous le dis
franchement vous êtes vous votre corps
et vous même
on n'est pas obligé de faire des choses
je n'avais pas
[Applaudissements]
elle préfère une boucle d'une embuscade
elles n'osent pas le dire elle veut que
ça avance elle veut que ça avance mais
je vous le dis mais non francesca ma
chérie je dis ça je dis pas mais qui
n'en démord pas ce que tu m'as dit que
tu admires croyez vous pouvez vous s'il
vous plaît arrêtez c'est important là
c'est la wii en attendant ça rigole avec
l'amour moi je jette mon tablier quand
je rends mon tablier
oh là là j'ai les mains moites à moi si
tu as un mec quand il fait ce cas
francesca je préfère que vous le disiez
vous mais ce que je me pose c'est qu'il
croit que les ou machin parce que ça
avait plus de règles annoncées pas une
bonne c'est quand même bizarre de plus
il a du coup de l'avoir eu la plus
désirée encore plus alors qu'ils
tenaient je vous dis oh c'est terrible
c'est mathieu non c'est qu'ils de
l'armature elle est amoureuse de mathieu
vraiment
oui
et c est cela et s'il vous plaît c'est
ce qu'a dû en amour parce qu'on a quatre
secondes on aura les réactions des
voitures de m' as tu seras aussi mais
les gens voient pas comment il est en
fait moi je sais comment il est il est
ultra sensible et on ne peut pas ne pas
l'aimer parce que le mec des drôles à
chaque fois qu'ils parlent d'amour un
jeune intelligent et il est magnifique
en plus j'ai vu vendredi avec une
chemise de bûcheron je bavais parce
qu'il était noir alors hamon prévoient
qu'il avait une chemise de bûcheron
ménages chic
il ne coupe pas que des bulles mettez
vous sur toulouse mais posé plusieurs
fois la question savoir s'il avait déjà
été avec des filles et il le dit donc
j'ai un petit test
alors je vous le dis c'est pas du tout
dire ça comme ça lance je t'adore
c'est pas du tout une bonne et elle
espère que ça va se faire un jour est
bon comme à mathieu sera là et ça y
regarde là il est au courant déjà envahi
valeur non ya pas de la voile à l'écurie
le dire ça et et franchement moi je te
kiffe de ouf et j'espère que ça va se
faire avec mathieu je rêverais à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas assez non pas
forcément
c'est les antisèches hip hop à on part
de loin mais lui les yeux bandés alors
vers ses normes et ses bons se passera
de vos commentaires merci elle est
amoureuse prendre jusqu'au bout et je
vais tout faire pour que ça se passe
bien est ce soir que je termine dîner
avec mathieu non la ronde
oui dès ce soir j'ai décidé de faire
[Rires]